Magic the Gathering's online client MTG
Arena lies to you and is teaching
players incorrect rules of the game. And
this isn't hyperbole. I'm seeing this in
real time in the comment sections of my
videos. Recently, I posted a short about
state-based actions, Sephro and the
Darkness Crystal, where spoilers, the
player loses the game and ends on two
life. And from this, I had a whole bunch
of people tell me I'm wrong and that
Arena does this differently. So, let's
clear this up. There are three main
comments I want to tackle. MTG Arena
lets you live with this example. MTG
Arena lets me heal up from zero or
negative life without losing. And Sephro
should have triggered and gained me a
life. Okay, let's start with the easy
one. MTG Arena lets you live with this
example. Thanks to the Cozy Magic Club
community for helping me pull this
together. I've set up the example in
arena. I'm on two life and I control
Sephro and the Darkness Crystal. My
opponent has two creatures, one of which
has two attack and I also have a death
toucher in play.
So, just like in the example, my
opponent is going to attack me with two
creatures. I'll block one of them,
assign lethal damage to it, and the
other will hit me for two. Let's see
what happens.
They attack, I block, we move to the
combat damage step,
and I lose the game, just like in the
short. But obviously here, there is one
small difference. I'm still on zero
life. Now, I just want to clarify by the
written rules of the game, we should be
on two life. As I mentioned in my short,
losing the game for being on zero life
and a creature dying due to lethal
damage are all things that occur due to
state-based actions.
And as per rule 704.3,
not 704.7 that I quote in the short, all
state-based actions are performed
simultaneously as a single event. Which
then leads me into what the darkness
crystal does. The darkness crystal has a
replacement effect. If a non-token
creature an opponent controls would die,
instead exile it and you gain two life.
So, the darkness crystal looks for a
dying creature event like the one we're
about to perform with the state-based
action and replaces the dying part with
exile the creature and gain two. Now,
what's really interesting, if you look
at the example again, we can see two
things. The animation for Ajani's
Pridemate is the exiling animation. And
after my avatar explodes, you can see
the pride mate under the darkness
crystal. So, it did get exiled and Arena
just didn't gain me two life. So, yes,
Arena is incorrect here. And yes, I get
that it's not a big deal and the outcome
is still the same, but it's important to
know that Arena isn't always correct.
Okay, next comment. MTG Arena doesn't
cause me to lose the game when I hit
zero life and allows me to heal back up.
So, this comment is interesting as
there's a single misconception that MTG
arena generates and it's all around the
combat damage step. Let's look at it in
action. So, my opponent is on two life
and they have a two three lifelinker in
play and I have two two twos. I attack
my opponent with the two two twos and
they block one of them. Now watch the
health total here. We move to the combat
damage step down to zero and then back
up to two. So here it looks like
lifelink happens after damage is dealt.
But in reality this is incorrect.
If you haven't already, I highly
recommend you go and watch my full deep
dive into the combat phase where I cover
all of this. But for this example,
there's two things you need to know.
Number one, combat damage is dealt
simultaneously by both attacking and
defending creatures. As per rule 510.2,
all combat damage that's been assigned
is dealt simultaneously.
Number two, the rules for lifelink tell
us damage dealt by a source with
lifelink causes that source's controller
or its owner if it has no controller to
gain that much life. So, put that all
together. As soon as a creature with
lifelink deals damage, you gain that
much life. And during combat, creatures
deal damage simultaneously.
You don't get to pick the order in which
creatures attack. So, this is just a
visual bug or a choice the developers
made. Most likely the latter to convey
what's happening easier. Last one.
Sephro should have triggered and gained
you a life. Arena actually demonstrates
this one correctly. Here I am on one
life with a Sepharoth in play, which
says whenever another creature dies,
target opponent loses one life and you
gain one life. If this is the fourth
time this ability has resolved this
turn, transform Sepharoth. My opponent
attacks me with two one ones and I block
one of them. We move to the combat
damage step. A one- one dies and I go to
zero and lose the game. If we take what
we've learned about state-based actions
from the short, we'll remember that
state-based actions are checked just
before a player would receive priority.
This is just before any triggered
abilities would get placed on the stack.
So in this example, before Sephro would
trigger thanks to the one one dying,
state-based actions would see me at zero
life and cause me to lose the game. Now,
are there any other MTG Arena lies or
interactions you want me to investigate?
Let me know in the comments down below.
Be sure to like the video if you learned
something and subscribe because if you
don't, I'll cast Sephro's intervention
on Aith. Thanks for watching and I'll
see you in the next